okay hey guys this is my second video
this is the overflows Delta scalper
analysis and you know Delta scalper is a
tool that I developed that reads the
orderflow Delta and now it reads uh some
of the price action that's coming in
there as well so you know it's quite a
powerful tool I'm going to show you uh
you know I've been creating these videos
every day for um this week to show you
how well it's been looking in in
different markets and you know I try to
keep the same markets every day but you
know if if you're not using Delta in
your trading you know you should you
know you're really leaving a very
important piece of information out Delta
is the reading of the net aggressive
buyers less the net aggressive sellers
so if you have positive Delta you have
aggressive buyers dominating the bar if
you have aggressive negative Delta you
got aggressive sellers in charge of the
bar so before I get in a brief
disclaimer this presentation for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a Futures
Contract or make any other type of
investment decision Futures training
contain substantial risk and is not for
every investor in investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results you know
again I always put that disclaimer in
all my presentations because you know I
want people to realize you know trading
is not easy you know trading there are
risks and you can lose money trading and
you know don't don't think that uh you
know you're going to buy a trading
indicator and you know make make a
bazillion dollars the next day or you
know in the next week and then you know
come back say oh I didn't make I didn't
make my million dollars uh you know
trading is a scam no I mean you know
trading takes works you know it it it's
not something that just naturally Falls
in your lap
so that that said little diet tribe
there um tools use in this presentation
are the uh Delta scalper again uh go to
Deltas scaler.com to learn more about it
and if your existing user uh email me
upgrade at deltas scalper and I'll get
you a copy out um ASAP it runs on ninja
Trader 7 and ninja Trader 8 so uh let's
take a look at some charts so really
quick first one we'll look at is uh
where is it
here I just had it up here sorry bear
with me
okay here it is sorry about that delay
um BNS not BNS bonds um five minute
chart look at this okay you get a buy
here a couple ticks here one or two
ticks sell doesn't work out stopped out
soell you know it starts coming off it
comes off the next two bars a few ticks
and then boom you get this beautiful
cell here um again you know I I'm not
want to I wish I had better patience
that you know you could get this this
move cuz it's all sells you know from up
here 153 even down to almost 152 but you
know here you getting a nice move say
you missed this one you at least you get
this next move here say you missed that
at least you got this move here as well
this buy fails so you got you know this
sell failed this buy
failed this one worked out initially the
first bar you know but again it's it's a
quick six
ticks this one you just went sideways on
you so you know you got a fail here
we'll call this one a fail fail here you
know fail here but you know you got nice
winner nice winner nice winner you know
I know people will email me sometimes
you know saying oh you know hey I use
this indicator and um you know I had
this losing trade two losing trades here
well did you catch this one no I didn't
I I I missed it or I missed this you
know part of being you know depending on
the type of Trader you are you know is
going to vary on the type of charts you
use you know if you only got an hour or
two hours a day to trade you shouldn't
be trading a 5-minute chart go to a
different a smaller range chart you know
you're going to get some more trades um
you know the worst thing you want to do
is is trade for an hour a day on a 5
minute chart and you know where you're
going to be getting you know it's going
to move slower you're going to get a lot
of signals but if you're just trading
during this time period each day you're
missing all this other stuff you know go
to a different type of chart you know
different range or you know a tick chart
or a small you know a one minute chart
or something I don't really Advocate um
you know trading on on you know 30
second charts or anything like that but
uh you know I I know people that do
actually but again it depends on your
your trading
style um yeah the bonds the bonds Pond
chart that was uh five year or sorry
that was the bonds where's my five-year
chart here's the five minute um fiveyear
chart very similar
um but but in this case you got uh a
little bit more buys than than the sells
that you had in the
bonds nice sell
here okay you this buy you know
initially it started working out you're
getting a few ticks a few ticks you know
some nice trade here a nice trade here a
nice trade here nice trade down there
and then you know the buy here you know
this one takes a long route before it
moves up um a nice sell there
okay um this is Japanese Yen this is the
eight range chart um you know early in
the morning 1:00 or so 1:15 get a buy
just go sideways on you get a buy just
go sideways on you you know so you got
two trades early in the morning you know
you're half asleep thinking oh you know
this sucks I I don't want to trade this
then you come in into the morning 10:00
boom you get another buy starts to work
out then a fails on you and you're
thinking oh you know what Mike I want to
kill you um and you stop trading for the
day because you know as many of these
quote gurus say you have three losses in
a row stop trading well if you do the
next signal you get right around the
corner is this
8980 getting long all the way up to uh
you know 9030 where you get the sell
signal so again you know this is why you
know when
people ask me to help them trade you
know I sit down and ask them you know
how much risk can you take you know
don't take your trading account and
divide it by four basically and say well
if I have three losses and are wrong I
stop trading no you know you you trade
at at a smaller percentage to your
account so even though you suffer a loss
here this is probably more of a break
even this is also more of a I'll say
Break Even but at least here you had you
know a chance to cover it before it
broke but again you know if if you have
three losses in a row instead of stop
trading for the day cut your size down
right if you trading five Lots go down
to one lot two lots you know if you're
trading one lot then yeah you have to
stop trading but
you know if you do sometimes you're
going to you're going to miss these
trades you're going to miss the moves um
you know because oh because everybody
says you have to stop trading after you
have three losses and no you don't right
it's like you know if you're a baseball
player you strike out three times in a
row you know you're still going to get
back up to the plate right you know it's
a percentage game you know it's it's a
numbers
game so you know yeah you are going to
have losses you know sometimes they're
going to come one right after after the
other and it sucks it really sucks to
get three losses in a row but don't get
discouraged you know try and keep at it
as long as you have faith in what you're
doing I mean you could have no idea what
the [__] you're doing and have three
losses in a row and the next thing you
know you got eight losses in a row CU
you have no [__] clue but you know if
you believe in what you're doing you
should stick with it you know it's easy
to get discouraged when you're losing
money you know you think oh [__] you
know I could have bought something I
could have taken the family on vacation
whatever I understand that but you know
if you get let that get to you you're
going to miss those trades that you want
to be
catching okay so that was the uh
Japanese Yen that was the eight range
chart I just showed you there eight
range no I'm going to show you the one
minute chart again same settings 711
252 you get traded here that failed this
one you know started to work out and
failed but then boom you get a nice
little winner here again you know traing
a one minute chart it's not like you're
buying it here at 2:30 in the morning
and you're getting out at at 7:00 in the
morning um you traing a one minute chart
your time frame should be pretty short
so you a nice winner here you got two
losing trades then you get a nice winner
a nice little winner here this one
failed um then you start coming into the
day session 7:30 the number came out you
know just before the number you know
7:15 you know for me the number you know
leading up to it liquidity gends to dry
up um yeah I'm not a big fan you know
probably about 15 minutes before you
know from 7: until
7:30 you usually I'm eating at that time
but um again you'll he right before you
got a little move down this one probably
stopped you out I I wouldn't take this
trade is at 7:30 7:45 it failed failed
then you know 8:30 so again you know say
you took this trade lost took this trade
you lost you took this trade you lost
and then you give up uh I had three
traders in a in a row my Guru says I got
to stop trading well if you
do you you're going to miss it you
you're going to miss the next trade that
you're supposed to be taking you know
boom it's just straight up you know it's
that's the move that you want but my
Guru says I got to stop trading after
three losses in a row and then you're
sitting here you're kicking yourself oh
you know I missed this trade oh you know
the trading is a scam you know Delta
scalper is a
scam because you know someone once told
me I had three losses in a row I got to
stop
trading and then you know you're kick
yourself kicking yourself and you turned
off your screen already then you miss
the next nice trade because you you
you've given up trading for the day so
you got this nice beautiful move up you
know from 89
88 you know well this is 88 right here
all the way up to you know 90 even then
a move from 90 even back down to 8980 so
you know then you this trade loses um
you know this was a nice this this one's
going to be difficult you know maybe you
could have scratched it you know I I
would love to have a buy here you know
people say oh you suck this sucks it
didn't tell me to buy here well [__] man
you had a nice sell here a nice buy here
you know he not going to catch every
single move so what what the market
tells you you know I know everybody
likes to have an indicator that's got a
buy here at the low and and a sell up
here at the high but you know what
there's there's enough meat in these
moves to be catching you know move like
this move like this is a minute chart
for God's sakes you know um you know
sometimes you don't necessarily get the
volume that you need um you get
signals okay I'm just showing this one
for shits and giggles it's a e- mini
15minute
chart you overnight you got a couple
buys a couple sells couple buys that
didn't work out during the day session
you got this beautiful sell um actually
even looks uh it looks nice there on the
15minute chart but I'll show you a chart
that it looks uh even even more nicer is
actually the
uh you know five minute chart here
same setting 71252 so I'm not optimizing
the settings for anything you know based
on time so you know early in the session
you you getting you know the sell here
then buy and Buy Here Sell blah blah
blah just going sideways you're in this
very tight range from um you know 2
until basically two until you start
breaking out at 11 uh 12 rather you know
80 is the high you know basically 77 is
the low so you're in this tight range
finally break out of it you get this Buy
Signal here okay yeah a little bit of a
move up then boom the Delta Scupper
gives a sell it's beautiful sell looks
much nicer that you know five this is
the 15-minute chart it's very dramatic
here but this one on the F minute chart
is is very beautiful from uh 76 all the
way down to you know down to the lows of
the day so you know nice 15-point move
you know I I know there's there's some
guys I'm on their mailing list you know
they they run these trade rooms for like
500 bucks a month or something they'll
say oh yeah you know I got this uh yeah
I got 20 ticks out of the snps today
just from turning on my system but I
mean come on you know those things make
me laugh but this is a nice move if you
could got it you know you should have
been able to catch that you know the
signs were there you know I I did my
other presentation on on orderflow and
you know the signs were there in in the
orderflow you know as far as volume
profile and value area highs and lows
for the last couple days you know again
we came into this day we're trading
right in inside your value area high
value area low look for a sign that
you're going to be breaking out you know
here boom there it is there's that
monster
breakout okay so British pound eight
range again same setting know that I'm
using you know an eight range British
pound chart that I'm using on oops this
is the euro currency I get that out
there the uh you know five minute chart
and the snps the 15minute chart in the
snps so it's not like I'm I'm optimizing
it it's the same settings okay so this
is British pound 2 in the morning get
this little buy rallies up here 5: in
the morning get a sell great you know
it's trading
13170 more or less in here and go
sideways and then boom look at that
monster
move from 130 170 down to you know below
13075 down in here so again you know
there was two signals here
and you know they're both nice ones
again you know I could show you chart
after chart after chart but again you
know it's you know you I've showed you
eight range charts I've showed you one
minute charts 5 minute charts 15minute
charts um what else you know can I show
you here you know a different type of
chart
um what do I got
here oh okay again I can show you this
100 tick chart you know Mini doar
this is on days where the Dow moves very
fast it's going to be very difficult to
really get good trade locations but I
mean look at this you know sells sells
you know this buy fails you got a nice
buy here a little sell here this one you
got to really have a short time frame
again it's not something trade should
work out immediately and go in your
direction if it's not that's a sign it's
not working
out but you know you're getting some
nice trades nice trades here not
everyone is going to be a beautiful
winner you know this a loser here this
one maybe got a little bit of something
out gives you a sell right on the low
that fails um you know nice winner here
this one nothing nice little winner here
again you know this is 100 tick chart So
you you're going to be you know in and
out of the market a lot and your your
time frame for holding the trade should
be very short you know some a nice
winner here nice little winner there
nice winner here so you know it's a 100
tick chart you know about as as micro
as you can
get okay so you know compare that this
is a 987 tick chart for the
snps just scroll back
here you know early in the morning you
you got you got a buy Here didn't work
out nice little sell here nice little
buy here little buy
there this one didn't work
out this one started to then failed
this one
failed this started too this one started
too this one this one unfortunately
would have stopped me out this one fails
a nice move here nice little move there
nice move here so you know even though
you have some losers right but you're
getting out really quick and you can let
your winners ride you know right here
right here you know these two trades
easily make up for many of these losers
that you just had
yeah let me just see if I got one other
chart I could pull in here to show you
since we're on the subject of tick
charts crude oil 987 tick chart you know
a lot of guys use 987 ticks in in crude
it's FIB number so let's see okay
nothing here early just before 7 o'clock
you got a buy Here
4835 goes all the way up to 4,900 pretty
much straight up I mean you had a
pullback here okay so maybe get out here
you know this is a nice 30 Cent move 60
Cent move
okay wait for the next trade and here it
comes right in here you know for 4860
all the way up to 80 it's another 20
cents this one fails this
one maybe be lucky to break even same
thing here this one also Break Even to
me this one not much but again you know
you got a move here but more importantly
you got this nice move here so again you
know I've showed you 987 tick charts 100
tick charts one minute charts 5 minute
chart eight range charts
you know it it's you know all the
different charts it's it's firing on so
again you know if if you're interested
in it go to Deltas scaler.com the
information is there on on how to get it
so thanks and bye-bye